so it's finally been announced
blood-borne DLC is coming on November
24th and it's called the old hunters I
Spy seven new weapons five new sets of
attire a couple of new bosses and some
lore implications so let's dissect that
trailer
let's do weapons first because it was
the weapons that really grabbed my
attention and it was the weapons I could
find a lot about just by watching those
clips over and over again so first up
let's talk about that circular saw blade
the pizza cutter as some are calling it
what I find most interesting about this
weapon is just how simple that
one-handed form appears to be when you
look really closely at it it's just this
thin iron bar with a flat sharpened end
but this bar is then lengthened and
jammed between the thick circular saw
forming this two-handed variation that
is slammed down on
Emelia towards the end of the trailer
I'm actually really curious to see the
move set of this weapon because what can
you do with a thin iron bar for the
shortened form and how do you wield a
pizza cutter when you're trying to
decapitate enemies I'm not sure next to
appear is this fascinating fiery
Warhammer it's probably the closest
thing we're gonna have to the lucern
from previous games this is the only
time it appears in the trailer but
there's a lot to be gleaned from this
short little clip now assuming that the
character here is tapping l1 which it
looks like he is you actually see that
he clicks open the back half of the
hammer which ignites in contact with the
air and then lends fire to your next
attack and I say next attack because
you'll notice that the long shot of
metal behind the hammer head only
appears in this frame here just after he
activates the fire and then it clicks
closed again after the attack is
finished and the fire goes away so
unlike the tinnitus where you tap l1 and
the effect remains for a while
l1 for the fiery war hammer appears to
be lending a burst of fire damage to
your next attack now the head of the
hammer is also not solid it's got these
holes for the fire to burst through upon
contact so that's my theory on this
weapon moving on we have what I'm going
to call the scythe cleaver
and
call it that because it's a mixture of
the scythe and the very standard saw
cleaver weapons now the shortened form
is similar to the common saw cleaver
except without the serrated blade and it
extends to this simple straighter scythe
than the one the way used to it appears
twice in the trailer with a similar move
set to the saw cleaver and the saw spear
weapons they currently exist so it's
pretty standard and kind of boring and
the next weapon though oh boy this looks
awesome it's a bow in blood-borne where
we have guns but I'm gonna use the bow
anyway it's amazing and if the DLC
blogpost is to be believed it's
technically a bow blade they call it
simon's bow blade and from the visuals
it's most logical to assume that the bow
sort of folds together to form a twisted
sort of sword or perhaps it's another
dual wielding weapon now since a bow has
a really bent structure it's possible
that it transforms into a twisted sword
and there is a twisted sword later in
the trailer but the shapes of the sword
and the bow are quite different so while
I initially thought they might transform
together they do seem distinct from one
another this twisted sword is
represented alongside a shield and it's
a shield that isn't just a plank of wood
which is nice next we have what I'm
going to call the chain cleaver I'm just
pointing phrases left and right here
it's move set is similar to the threaded
cane which extends like a whip when you
swing it but this weapons a little bit
different it looks significantly heavier
and more like a bludgeon type of weapon
and from a look at those solid metal
pieces here it looks as if the weapon
can be condensed down into more of a
bludgeon type of weapon here's what I
came up with after about 10 hours in
Photoshop that looks kinda legit next we
see a weapon that we're all familiar
with it's the Beast claws they're not
that great in the current game but it
looks almost like they are getting a
buff in the expansion so the character
here is performing a dive attack that
doesn't exist in the current game so how
does this attack come about well I
hypothesize that it's got something to
do with the character being more beast
like you look at the character here and
he has fur on
his back and his shoulder that extends
way more than it used to in the current
game so the Beast Clause was a weapon
that whenever you hit an enemy you get a
bit of beasts hood so maybe when your
beast hood meter is fuller you get
access to another move or something like
that I think it could be a clue that
beast hood is becoming a more developed
mechanic which is something a lot of
people have always wanted and I'd wager
that that's what you're looking at here
and finally we have this clip of a
hunter fighting the abhorrent beast in
the forbidden woods and his weapon in
its shortened form is this simple
one-handed pike you know like a spear
but the metal spike at the tip can
rotate perpendicularly and it can clip
to become a long pickaxe type of weapon
I'm gonna call it the pike axe and that
pretty much does it for weapons so let's
move on to attire and we'll go over it
pretty quick there's these three hunters
in the intro one of which is touting the
biggest hat we've seen since Dark Souls
1 there's a character you spot briefly
here on the right later in the trailer
wearing a red garb with puffy pants and
then the most curious outfit to me is
this one it's worn by the guy who's
wielding that circular saw blade and
look at that helmet it's like a metal
bucket does that look familiar
so story wise the dlc is said to be set
in a nightmare world where hunters from
the past are trapped forever the
playstation blog mentions that we will
be learning the tale of hunters who once
made yharnam their hunting grounds and
will experience the nightmare of hunters
who once guarded Bergin Worth's darkest
secrets so there's a lot of buzzwords
there but I guess the question is that
how did the hunters of the past get
trapped here could this DLC be taking
place in another Nightmare Realm similar
to menses where characters of the past
have been ripped to another realm I
guess that's my theory until we have
anything better but another interesting
thing is the time of night in
blood-borne the color and the size of
the Moon has always indicated what world
phase that you're in currently in the
game there is afternoon/evening
and the Blood Moon and each of these
indicates the passing of time as you go
through the night of the hunt and the
enemies and the environment changes as
you go through this night this shape in
the sky of the trailer doesn't look like
a moon though it looks more like a son
to me or a sort of distorted rift and it
hangs over the city of yharnam
indicating to me that the old areas of
the game could be changing a bit as well
think about it this expansion might be
more than just adding a new area it
could intend to alter the enemies and
the environment of the existing world
are giving us a new phase to explore the
world in and I kind of think this is
likely considering we see an alternate
version of the sewers with blood going
through the ground and corpses and we
also see the lumen flower gardens with
new NPCs and finally not to mention the
flaming cleric beast who is an alternate
version of an existing enemy so we could
be seeing some revamping going on which
is pretty hype but the main boss of the
dlc has been teased to be Ludwig who was
once the first hunter of the healing
church and yeah that's pretty much
everything we know about the DLC it
sounds really good so far I think that
more weapons means more longevity and
that's great because the one thing the
blood-borne likes is that longevity and
the variety that the Soul series offers
so you know weapons is a good way to
solve that there are two little weapons
in the current game but I'd also like to
see some better PvP areas and maybe
better covenant rewards and stuff that
you really have to earn that's something
that blood-borne lacks and I really hope
that's something blood-borne adds but
what are you looking forward to let me
know subscribe if you want to keep on
top of everything blood-borne related
going forward I'm really craving some
new content sometimes it's tough just
doing souls but yeah I just can't wait
to jump into it with you guys explore it
all and I'll see you all in the next
video